ladies and gentlemen
I'm a former Oscar winner for best
actress currently starring on Broadway
in victor/victoria Miss Julie Andrews
good evening on certain occasions the
Board of Governors of the Academy deems
it appropriate to present an honorary
award for exceptional distinction in the
making of motion pictures and tonight
I'm pleased to announce the Academy
deemed it appropriate to bestow one of
these rare Oscars on a most worthy and
creative artist a dear friend and my
favorite curmudgeon director
choreographer Michael king
when Michael kid was summoned to
Hollywood he had already established
himself on Broadway as a brilliantly
inventive choreographer and winner of
five Tony Awards he worked in close
collaboration with such gifted directors
as Gene Kelly Stanley Donen and Robert
Wise and in classic films like Guys and
Dolls and Hello Dolly he was allowed to
work as an autonomous second unit even a
casual review of his dances for films
reveals his inspired gift for expressing
emotions through motion and in all of
his work emotional content takes
precedence over mere spectacle in the
fabulous barn-raising dance number he
created for Seven Brides for Seven
Brothers
Michael was told simply we need
something here it's it's a big gathering
well he turned that gathering into an
exhilarating Rite of courtship and
competition that still leaves audiences
breathless
in recognition of your services to the
art of the dance in the art of the
screen the Board of Governors of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences is proud to present you with
this honorary Oscar congratulations
Michael
Thank You Jules Jules you're treasurer
for being here
thank you I didn't know how to handle
all this but my wife Sheila who was my
assistant many of these pictures and
naturally bore the brunt of my
grouchiness said to me Michael the
Academy is honoring you for once stop
being mr. bah humbug and try to enjoy it
at least via family and friends sake
well she's not only beautiful she's
right so Sheila and Matthew Amy Chris
and Susan and even Julie who calls me an
old curmudgeon and the many friends who
wrote or phoned with the same message
once the reality of all this sinks in I
promise to enjoy it
I've even had my glasses tinted slightly
rose-colored so many of today's films
stress the terrors that our waiters
perhaps this award signifies an
awareness that we have been missing
something
namely the vitality and the joy of
living that movie musicals can express
in song and dance
I thank the Academy for this tribute I
accept it in the name of all
choreographers and especially the
dancers who made it all possible
we feel honored
be back in a moment with Helen Hunt
Tommy Lee Jones Will Smith and another
oscar-nominated song